taylor you do if i took you home  to meet my parents and my mom was hotter  than me is your mom single no good  answer  i would say this is a great future to  look forward to okay so brian so if i  put on a dress and it did make me look  fat like i didn't look great in it and i  asked does this dress make me look fat  what would you say i'ma say you do look  fat but not that fat i'ma say you look  funky fast with the ph okay i mean like  every time i walk out like dang y'all  she looks funky fat up in this place  what  okay if the boys were to ask you  to go out i said whatever have fun what  would you do i don't have any boys um if  the situation were to happen  i'd probably just invite you to come  along i have to eliminate brooke because  i told you i'm into guys  brooke i i messaged you my number just  in case i mean you're really cute  max what the  what